Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included. Now, if you know about this game,
you know that it is my comfort game.
I love this game so much. When I load up the game, and I hear the music,
I just get this sense of relaxation and calm. But I haven't played the game in a while,
and there's been two additional updates since the Outbreak update that caused germs to run rampant in my facility.
This is the Automation upgrade and the Tubular upgrade. Now, I don't know exactly what these do, and I need to clean my glasses,
they're gross! Probably all the raging I just had over Getting Over It. Why am I playing this game?
Well, because I just played Getting Over It and I need to relax.
I need to get my family in space,
and I need to take them through a generation of survival,
and I don't care if they're clones, babies, whatever they are; they're gonna survive in this place,
they're gonna eat a lot of bugs…and everything is gonna be wonderful. Because I'm a caretaker.
I take care of things. I take care of people. They are not things, they're people, and everything is going to be wonderful
because I know how to play this game, unless they change something fundamentalllllalalalalal
about the game with the other updates, which they may have. Germs are still bad, as far as I know.
Ooookay, let's do dis. Now, immunity is important.
Eh, Mole Hands, that's some bullshit, fuck off.
Oooh. That's almost—Rowan! Oh, Rowan, you're so cute, and you're so good at everything except…
You know what? I'm gonna keep you. I'm gonna, I'm gonna not go for just the immunity ones,
I li—I want to go for ones that…ring true to…to—ooh. I like Ada. Oh you're cute, but no…
Mae…Ruby…Mi-Ma—Miiii-Maaaa!
Mi-Ma's buff! Buff Mi-Ma! Oh, Mi-Ma so strong!
Okay, all right. We got Mi-Ma, we got Rowan, we got Stinky. A whole generation—
I'd like to think that this is one big family, like this is Mi-Ma the grandma, the really buff bodybuilder
There's Stinky, the papa, he's…stinky…and then Rowan's the little kid. Rowan likes to dig. I like this!
Panopticon?
Spacepad, Ironic League, Ironic—Darkest—Darkest Dreamland!
[coughs] I almost choked, that was such a brilliant idea! Great, let's get into this! Okay, all right. Oh.
Alert! It's all bad here! Everything's horrible. All right, let's get a scope of the land here.
Okay, you all remember how to play? 'Cause I do! So. We need to make them not poop in the water;
that's rule number one. Number two:
Let's f—ah, we gotta build—
we gotta get to researching pretty soon, because I gotta figure out what else they got going on,
because they've done a lot of new stuff in this.
Ah God, I gotta go all the way up there for the metal; I don't need that bullshit. Okay.
So we're starting over all the way at the beginning again because, as with most of these updates,
the save system doesn't work as well, so we have to do what we gotta do, so we're starting over at the beginning,
which means that I'm gonna be accelerating a lot,
and I'm gonna be flying by the seat of my pants on how good I am at buildin' shit…ain't that right everybody?
"Oh, yeah, that's right! Oh, that is so right!"
But I gotta get metal before I'm able to build anything else.
How about you stop sittin' around with your hands up your ass, and you go get the metal? Go get the metal!
Come on, man!
Oh shit, the bathroom. I almost forgot about the bathroom.
Dat is…unbeliebably important.
Okay. Need the sink there; go put those things, because I'm very particular about clean-a-li-ness;
We need to get a plump pitcher…
Gotta have ta PUMP pitcher! Gotta get dat dere—d'okay, go!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
How 'bout—wait, I forgot, you gotta make this priority, because otherwise people are gonna shit themselves…
and that ain't good for nobody! All right, come on, go go go go go goooo!
I almost always forget about the poopin' station, 'cause if you forget about the poopin' station then you're gonna…
I mean, you're…
You're gonna have a lot of poop. That's pretty much the long and the short of it,
you're gonna have a lot of poop where you don't want poop, and where you don't want poop is in your water.
You don't want poop in water. That's like—that's Markiplier Life Lesson number one:
You don't want poop in your water, so keep your poop outta your water,
you're gonna have a great time. And then you're gonna live life.
Then you're probably gonna die anyway 'cause something else bad's gonna happen. But don't poop in your water!
That's first and foremost about everything that we got over here.
So I don't know about the Automation upgrade, but we gotta get power going real soon…
Let me get beds for 'em; actually, I'm not gonna—
I'm gonna make it, like, a policy not to pause,
because I have a habit of doing that, but I'm gonna…
I'm gonna really try not to pause, because there's, uh, there's so much to be done here,
but I know that I can do it good, and I can do it justice if I juuust…
Ooh. If I just verrry stateegerically…plan everything that I got going on.
'Cause if I don't, then I'm boned, but I'm not boned because I'm smart like you—
Theeeere, finally, we're getting med-dal! Oh wow, we got the med-dal, oh who'da thought? Ah—just in time for sleep,
yeah, that's good.
Alright, fa—why—what is—uh, whuuuut?
Did I mention I'm on one of the betas?
So…prepare for some strange functionality, because…I don't know what's on their chin;
maybe that's just the familial chin, the Stinky, Mi-Ma and Rowan Family chin redness
that they have going on there. They got that, we got a little bit of…
huh, oxygen flowing over there, so the next thing we gotta do is we gotta get power going,
then we gotta get the research going, so I'm gonna build a ladder up…here, because this is gonna be the research area…
Ooh, there's a lot of goodies in there,
but I don't want to dig too deep 'cause it's about to get germy! Let's actually not dig deep.
Let's actually not—that's not a priority at all. That is the opposite of a priority right now. Okay.
Okay. So then we're gonna builllld…
our manual—wow that wire is so nice! The wire is, like, red now! That's real…
…I don't like that, actually; something feels wrong about that. Hmm.
Alright, whatever. It's fine. At least I got enough metal for that.
Alright, get that done, get that done, get that doooooooone! ♫
[singing] Kill that muck, kill that Haaaatch…
[singing]…kill that Haaaaatch…
Come on now, kill that Hatch! Oh, you sack of shit. Rowan!
Ro—Mi-Ma, you don't have to do everything, Mi-Ma! You're such a hero!
Aww!
Uh-UEHH-uh!
Okay, kill that Hatch, kil—kil—kill…
Kill! Kill the Hatch! Oh, I paused again, I'm sorry. I'm trying not to do that!
Mi-Ma's just…
Mi-Ma's just like, "Eh, been through this before!"
"It's not the worst thing in the world!"
I dunno why Mi-Ma's from whatever country that accent I did was from.
Nowhere? Oh yeah, that place. Yeah. But now that we got this, we can actually see the research tree, which means that we're gonna…
Ok—whoooa. Ahhhhh!
Whoaaaaaoooouuughhhhhhh…
[struggling to form words]
Auhhh.
Oaaaghh!
Transit Tube? What?!
Transit tube?! So they get sucked in like Futurama, and they get sho—oh, the Tubular update!
Oh, that makes sense!
Ahh, Comfy Bed! Plastic Tile!
Aaaiuuuoeogh!
There's so much shit!
Well, gotta start somewhere. Let's get farming up and ready to go, but daaaaaaaamn!
Daaamn! Even from the last time I played—that's the thing I love about this is that they update the game sooo much.
Like so ridicul—what are you doing? Rowan, stop being—oh, I can't do that.
Rowan, stop being idle, go get some…damn whatever that is. And…get it…ready, I guess. Damn it, okay.
Alright, so we gotta dig this down, we gotta dig this, uhhhh…
That water supply needs to connect to that water supply, but we gotta—mmmm.
We gotta, like, robust that out, but let's put some storage containers like…right…ooh. Let's also get a door…
Oh, let's also get these wash basins only to the right; that way people don't use them on the way in.
Even though I do want kind of one of them to be on the way in, just in case, you never know. You never know!
You never know—Rowan, please…
Stop being an idiot, please. That's all I ask.
So once we get that—oh! Oop! Oh! Eut! Ut!
Hup!
Heeeeey! Alright, we got that, alright, let me see what the next one is: power regulation, sure. Alright.
So now that we got that, we can start our food growin' operation, because we're gonna need food right away.
Bebedeh—I don't have time to be very bad. I think this room needs to be…ehhhhhhh,
no, that definitely doesn't need to be there. Okay, 'cause this is gonna be a door, and a door, 'cause we are civilized!
That's what we is.
Definitely.
You're gonna be there…
you're gonna be a door, and you're gonna be there, and you're gonna be there,
and then we're gonna build…more food, because we don't have enough people to survive!
Okay, what do we have? Do we have seeds? Oh, you know we got seeds, baby, you know we got seeds!
Oh, you know we got seeds! Let's put these bad boys right there,
sure—it's kind of an open-air design around that…
big ol' portal thingy, because we want to make sure that we got the decorum all nice and pretty-like.
Refinement, Compost, you know it, baby!
Let's put that compost—well, we don't exactly have a locked door.
Nnnnnnggghh, also, who's best at researching? Uh, not Mi-Ma.
Eh, they're pretty good, I guess. Okay. We're doing good. We're doing good. We're doing good. Okay.
All right. Cool, cool, cool. We got two bits of research done. What do we need, Advanced Research?
Oh, you gotta do that before you get anything else, do you now? Okay, alright.
Well, let's go ahead and do that—Automatic Control! [gasp]
"Enables access to the Automation Overlay?" "Power Shutoff automatically turns Power on and off using Automation technology?"
"Does not…affect circuitry preceding the switch."
Signal Switch. Automation Wire Bridge. Automation Wire. Generic Sensors. Weight Plate. What? Oh, that's so cool!
Clock Sensor. Ohhh! Auuwhhh!
I don't know, I'm never gonna—Fireball?!
Fireball?!
I love that!
Brute Force Refinement, "Produces Sand from Raw Minerals."
"Inefficiently produces Refined Metals from raw Metal Ore." Oh!
Well, then! That answers the question of filtration; there's finally a way to make sand!
Ohhhh! Smelting, "Produces Refined Metals from raw Metal Ore; outputs heat—significantly heated liquid." Heated liquid?
What kind of "heated liquid" we talking about, we talking about lava?
Sounds like we're talking about lava.
Why are we talking about lava?
I'm not talking about lava, you're talking about lava!
Alright, whatever. We're gonna need more plants than that after a while, but…for now that is is what it is.
So that's good. Can you dig that out please, please, please can you dig that out?
Okay, so far so good. Okay! Our next patient is Ari? Mmm, Diver's Lungs.
I always like a diver! And Learning, which means that you can be better at everything once you get your head out of your ass.
Iron Gut, nnn, Uncultured, no…you know what, I like you, Ari! I like you, Ari!
Ari? Oh, everybody got a new friend, okay.
But that's the only one that we're gonna get for a while, because I don't want to be…I don't want to be in the precarious situation
of not having enough room for anybody, so…Ari's gonna be up there by herself.
So have fun with that, Ari.
We also need to get oxygenation going, because the oxygen—ah, can't stop.
Okay, the oxygen is not doing bad because we got this Oxylite that's flowing upwards,
but we're gonna need the airflow tiles eventually before we're able to get anywhere else,
so we gotta make sure we have that.
'Cause if we don't have that…well then we're boned!
Hate to say it, but we're just gonna be straight-up boned!
Oh, there's so many goodies up there, let me make sure…just to give my people something to chew on,
let's get these goodies…let's get those goodies. Let's just eco-terrorism our way through this shit.
Ah, jeez, those guys are gonna get a mouthful.
Okay, but so far so—aww, really? Aw, Ari is asleep on the ladder? Ari, come on!
Just move the sand! Just a little bit! Come on now!
Oh come on, move the sand a little bit.
Oh come on—ah shit, they're eatin' all the reezerzes!
Dammit, I like the rezerces that we have. I'm not gonna kill too many of them, 'cause eventually I want to hurt 'em all…
Herd, not hurt, herd them all into cages so that I can create a coal production facility, because these things eat…
…the things that I need, but also they shit out coal, so it's like a fifty-fifty.
I mean if I had a…if Chica just started shittin' out coal, like…
One, I'd be worried about what I was feeding her, but Number Two,
That might be a profitable business, so I gotta be very savvy about it.
Let's just get all the basic shit out of the way, we'll—
I'm gonna build a supercomputer here, and we're eventually gonna get that up and running, but for now…we gotta get this.
Rowan!
Rowan, stop bein' a stupid shit! You're be—right now you're bein' a bit of a stupid shit. I don't like it.
I don't like it. Not at all, Rowan. Will you stop being so stupid. Okay, we need to get oxygen.
So we need algae terrahhhriums.
But, if we do have the situation where we're gonna have a lot more water because of the filtration that we're gonna be having,
then this offers an interesting solution.
That we're gonna be able to have, I think, I think, I thunkalunk. So you need a carbon dioxide environment;
I'm thinking that I'm gonna put ye…right…
uh, right by the water is gonna be a good spot for yeh.
You're gonna need, ah, I guess you're gonna need a floor of some kind, if I have to, I guess.
Yeah, all right, sure, whatever. Let me see if I can extend this ladder down;
I know they're gonna get hypothermia, but whatever, do I actually care? No.
You, you, you, you…alright.
Why is that considered grisly? This is stupid.
I wonder if they—I wonder if they—I wonder if they…mmm.
I wonder if they did anything different about the microbe crusher? Because if they actually made the cooking a little bit better than maybe…
maybe it might be good to go for that, but for right now…
Ah, no, y'know, I'm gonna go for the meal prep and hopefully there's gonna be something good there—
Why do you have…?
Ari? Ahri? Aree! Aree! Rrrrrrree!
Rrrrrreee! Arri! Arri! Arri. Arri. Arri. Ari.
Okay, alright, well then. I don't know why she had the red dot on her chin, but okay.
Alright, who's gonna be stinkin' up a storm here? You guys got your jobs all in order? Yeah, that's good.
Alright, we got…we got a world-class diggin' guy.
I know we should use that, but for right now, I just hate to assign people to individual jobs this early on.
Don't want to ruin 'em, 'cause if we got those going, that's a little bit of something, and these light bugs are gonna give it some light!
Aaaaahhhh, that's so nice!
And at least they got a lot of carbon dioxide down there, so…that seems to be a pretty effective trap for 'em.
I'm gonna put another one down here, but that's later. So far so good. No stopping on this train, honk honk!
We're going forward, so that's something good to look forward to—
we need to get more…we're gonna need to get more Mealwood, definitely,
sooner rather than later. I'm just gonna need to go for the airflow stuff, like the…
the, the, pneumatic doors—ah, do they move—uhhhhhhh, no.
Yes.
No.
Yes. Mechanical—no. Yeah! Pressure Management!
Okay, we need to get Ventilation after we have the next one, and then we need to go for Pressure Management.
There are a lot of you! You better not eat my metal.
Y'know what? Just as a safety precaution I'm gonna sweep up that metal.
I don't know where we're gonna sweep it to, we don't have any…
Well, I guess we should make some storage containers, shouldn't we? Rrrrrunk! Well, that—
sorry, I got drunk for those two seconds I was holding down the button.
I paused it again, too, which is…a big no-no on the Markimomo! So we got this…Supercomputer…
Oh, is that new music I hear?
I would recognize the new music because I know all the songs in this;
I played it so much, I've got eighty-four hours logged in this game, by the way. Heh.
Ahhh, I am pathetic. Alright.
Well that Hatch seems to be stuck! Hey, buddy! Mi-Ma, did you see that shit? Mi-Ma, did you see this Hatch? It's…stuck!
I dunno, weird, but okay.
Alright, so that research is done, so the next we're gonna go for is Pressure Management.
I'm just gonna set that to task, we're gonna get those underway.
Doodly-doo, de-doodle-doodly-doo—you know, it gets a lot easier when you don't have too many Duplicants,
and then you don't have to feed them and worry about them suckin' up so much oxygen.
Things actually go a lot smoother when you just do that.
Oddly enough. Weird, huh. Oh, that is new music! Oh, that's delightful!
Oh, that's a bounty to my ears! Oh, that's beautiful!
Gaauugh, I love it! Okay, who's stressed?
Ari, huh, probably 'cause of that spot on her chin, but she's gonna be okay.
Just a little strip mining; that's it, not too much.
I don't wanna give him impossible-to-complete tasks.
From here on, we need to make sure the oxygen is good,
we need to make sure the food flow is good,
we need to make sure that everything is good,
and then we can start hammerin' away on the big bonkin' bomper stuff, as I like to call it,
the big bompin' bomper stuff. Ooh! A Natural Gas Geyser?
Well, that's awfully handy. Do we have any other good geysers and shit around?
Uhhhh, some water leaking through there, which might mean that there's something up there,
but I don't think so; eh, might just be the little bit of water that is in those pockets there.
Nah.
Doesn't look like it.
Rrroeoeoioiorrrrourrrr-blelll, blel, blew!
And remember, the oil…the Oil upgrade, I forgot about that one—the Oil upgrade is, ah…
In the hot area, as I should have suspected, but I'm no—I'm not gonna worry about that for a long time.
I've got a long way to go before I get there, but I'm not gonna…
not gonna take that long to do it, because I'm gonna make sure that I survive right here and right now.
Alright. I'm gonna get more planter box up on this thing right here…
seems like as good a place as any. I've got that…alright, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Alright, go to sleep, little baby-boos!
We got Ventilation, which means that we got the thing that we need to be able to make that.
I wish you could just, like…I wish you could just…
I wish you could just place that over and it would do that, because that'd be a smart thing to do.
Just like "blam," and then it's on there, but no, alas, that is not what we're doing.
Wakey wakey, eggs and bakey, come on! We gotta go, we got a lot of stuff to do, alright.
We'll put that there. I know, it's gotta get real…
real oxygen-deprived in there, but at least it's…y'know,  gonna be okay.
Wait, is there any polluted dirt happening over there?
Wait, no, that's—oh, no, wait, hang on cancel that, cancel, wait. No. That's right.
I wanted to do that, and then put the mechanized airlock here,
so I could get the refinement, so I could turn our poop into fertilizer!
That was what I was doing! And then I ne—aww, that's right. I needed to create a dump for all the polluted water!
That's what I needed to do. That's what I needed to do.
That's what I needed to do. Okay, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it. So they're gonna get that eventually—oh, our first harvest!
Hell yeah…oh hell yeah, we got more Mealwood seeds.
Hey, you assholes need to dig out this stuff, did you know that? Did you not know that? I bet you didn't know that.
Uuuuugh! All right, they're getting to work.
Whoa!
…What?
Oh, okay, all right, well, Mi-Ma just took a beatin', holy shit! Mi-Ma, you okay?
Oh, Mi-Ma's not doing so good.
Oh no, "moderate wounds," awwww!
That's so sad!
Mi-Ma, I'm sorry! I mean you're really strong, so that kind of helps out your situation,
But goddamn, you…you deserve better than that, Mi-Ma.
[singing] I don't care if you have to eat worms;
[singing] it doesn't mean a difference to me.
[singing] I don't give a shit, you're gonna eat worms, and it's gonna be good so shut your fucking mouth.
Fifth perthon?
Only if they're really convincing. Max…ooh, look at your twinkle toes. Uh, and germ-resistant. That's good.
We got Meep!. Oh, look at that unibrow! But a mouth breather; never gonna happen.
Ooh, Frankie! Noodle Arms, very immune.
Lotsa…
Ohh, Frankie, I like ya. I like ya, and I like your noodle arms, I do, I really do!
"There's nothing Frankies are more proud of than their thick, dignified eyebrows."
Oh, you know what, Frankie, I like you Frankie.
Oh, I like ya, Frankie!
I don't want to go—but five! Alright, no more than five! No more than five, none. No more than five.
I like Frankie. The only reason is because I'm totally biased…and I'm…
I'll change my mind of what I want at the drop of a hat;
It's just how I am, it's how I am it's just how I am, everybody.
Wham, we're gonna close this up, and then that's gonna be a room, because once that turns into a room, there's a little bit of—whoo.
There's a little bit of a bonus to it if it's a barracks room. It's gonna have a stamina recovery bonus, stress relief bonus,
bonus bonus, mess hall bonus, stress relief for the mess hall bonus;
we're gonna make that soon. We're gonna make a big-ass mess hall…that's gonna be nice. Probably make it up here since there's space.
Alright—and then we're gonna make a med bed bonus, we're gonna have a bonus bay,
gonna have a bonus, bonus baby, bonus, baby, and that's gonna be it. Okay!
But! That's all the time that I got for this episode. This is a good start.
We're making progress here, and it's good to be back in this game. I do love this game, a lot.
I really do. There's nothing, like, about it that I don't like about it: the challenge of it,
the…the intricacy of it that—the, like, struggle to survive of it, and the constant progress, just…
and updates just make it super fun across the board.
So thank you everybody so much for watching;
let me know what you think down in the comments below!
There's gonna be more coming at you real soon, so thanks again,
and as always, I will see you…in the next video.
Bye-bye!